if you're sitting and watching right now
and you're 28 and you don't have
end
you can get like it's okay just because
you're not winning at 23 or 27 or 32
you're not finished we're in the first
quarter i started my company at 34 years
old in another company's conference room
because we had no money i was 34 before
i ever made a hundred thousand dollars a
year how old are you
you got time like you can go hard for
three years do nothing right wake up and
be youngest
when is it time to panic 70 70. because
colonel sanders came out with some kfc
it's late there's some people watching
right now that are 25 and they like feel
like sad because they're not a
millionaire that's asinine like you can
accomplish a lot everyone's so anxious
everyone wants it so fast everybody
wants to keep up with the joneses they
want to make it now so they can show or
enjoy like to me enjoy the process of
your career not the money you make from
your career so you can then enjoy it
and that's the game i play
[Applause]